today's episode is brought to you by the
US Army hello screen junkies welcome to
honest trailer commentaries I'm watching
commentaries mother yes we are that's
Joestar stage right to my right stage
left stage that is stage right mm-hmm it
is the direction if you were looking out
at the audience then stage right is the
right of the stage name Danny someone
you shot a lot of theater I was a techie
yeah in high school and you're on my
left yes I am so carrier under Gerber
then all the time well well tool know I
was in the booth oh nice yes well in
addition to what we've done in our past
this show is about the honest trailer
you hopefully just watched ready player
one if you stick around to the end
you'll see our little box of tricks what
we cut out of the episode
this one was live tested before a
comic-con audience so the things that
they didn't laugh at you'll get to see
at the end yeah
that is always a very harrowing
experience the live one yeah I think
it's very helpful because it's super fun
yeah yeah I mean I don't there's always
that moment where you just prefer the
first laugh or you're like this could
just go poorly this could be real bad
yeah but like I I'm actually grateful
for them for it because if a joke bombs
it's like we still have a week or so to
fix it be our canary be our dead canary
in their dead bird that's the kind of
show we promise to put on you may die of
what killed the canary in the coal mine
anyways was a mess
yes yeah methane gas just gas or giant
spiders yeah yeah good freaks oh yeah
that wasn't a mind to it was I'm great
mine yeah the kid dirtbiking around in
the mind it's gotta be was the Goonies
in a mine or a cat just a regular cave
okay yeah loads it well wasn't it
started in a while yes sorry well
started at the bottom now it's a well
Lord of the Rings had a good cape scene
good well that wasn't mine I wasn't mine
several mines and caves yeah if it seems
like we're just listing random
pop-culture references because we're
talking about ready player one this
we're seeing the movie in action
remember this can I just I'll admit it
jump in I like this movie by far the
most of the three of us yes I think I
think you did I'm in the middle Joe you
hated it and I this is just the way
truth works the middle is always the
correct absence of action no matter how
atrocious one side of the other is the
middle is always the right answer
definitely [ __ ] just going kind of yeah
anyway we heard risk of getting
dangerously off-topic
oh boy again yeah I didn't hate this
movie but I also didn't find it as
repellent as a lot of other people Joe
why did you find it repellent but you
knew stopped okay about 10 minutes and I
paused the movie and just turn to you
and I hate this at no point did that
Spielberg wonder really ever kick in for
me no I know there was like the big
chase scenes but I just sort of felt
like I was watching Final Fantasy
cutscenes at times I mean those are
pretty good I mean I mean yeah they are
they really are it's God that movie was
boring but the Spirits Within yeah it's
really excited for that like finally a
feature-length cutscene I think I feel
like not seeing it on the big screen is
it's one of these where does you a
disservice because I thought that that
chase scene was like classic Spielberg
like as far as just like knowing how to
stage an action scene and just I love
that's maybe my favorite part of the
movie that and the other part that Joe
paused and went
and I looked at the screen and it was my
other favorite part of the movie The
Shining thing which I loved and it was
like Oh God well a couple things
yeah go ahead Jeff well I was gonna say
it's not that the action is staged
poorly I think it lacks or for me lacked
the other things that make Spielberg
action or really any good action scene
sort of step above caring about the
people that are in it and being invested
in the storyline that the action is
trying to tell and I just didn't didn't
like participle I didn't like yeah me
and and like I didn't care about P I
didn't care about is his adventures in
the oculus or powering up yeah yeah I
just just the the whole thing as a whole
you know there wasn't it was a big
uphill battle for me as soon as I was
sort of plugged in and I was like they
got to control the okay yeah fine so
yeah I wish they'd read the book years
ago I've never read the book it's it's
fine it's like it's it's a popcorn book
it's like it's like a summer beach read
for for boys it's like oh that was fun I
like rush references I'm a sucker for
that which they did not have enough yeah
it was barely any rushing it was like a
poster or a t-shirt but right every
supposed to be a lot more 70s and 80s
heavy it seemed like they nineties did
up a little yeah one of the the race
didn't exist that wasn't a challenge I
was invented for the movie and the other
key a challenge that didn't make it
movie was quoting all of Matthew
Broderick's lines from war games from
memory yes and I really wish instead of
The Shining that the whole movie had
just stopped and had become war games
but but the CGI Matthew Broderick just
quoting every single line what yeah that
was the challenge was you find yourself
inside wargames but you were him and you
need to do everything
[Laughter]
which would have been a really good
second act I think it's just they don't
obviously do every line which is the
screenplay format that would have been
amazing yeah you know and that would
have been better to me than the test
that there were because I think
especially with gamers here's where the
premise became difficult for me because
the puzzles were ridiculously shallow
because gamers especially like really
hardcore programmers Cramer's
programmers programmers
it's like Gunter's but pro gamers they
just immediately want to break a game
and so the idea that he's the first
person to ever just drive backwards in
that race like bobbitt like the first
thing I did was I was like left yeah and
then Mario with this far someone removed
my action okay yeah we do it by accident
or something so or that he was the first
person to just keep watching that one
video of videogame Willy Wonka until he
talked about Bill and Ted yeah I mean to
me my I guess my issues are broader in a
sense where it was like it was a really
interesting world to set a movie in and
I thought it was like very applicable to
our present-day situation in a lot of
ways and it was like a really cool
portrait of where we might be going and
then they didn't really deal with it
enough it was like for me it was a
reverse matrix equal where it's like I
actually wanted him to spend more time
out of the oasis less time you know
virtual shopping I was so curious about
like wow how are they gonna use what's
in here to cure what's out there and it
was like basically a throwaway line in
the epilogue of like you get Tuesday's
off now oh cool but everyone's still
poisoned and like and now it's just you
replaced the everyone still lives in
champagne early there's with kids no ads
no ads I feel like we can talk about
this movie a lot should we or should we
keep talking sure watch trailers rocks
the trailer let's watch
trailing single take your time stamps
yeah so that we can delete them from the
comments said please three times thank
you for being so polite
yeah uses they selling a few in a world
where every movie is based on
pre-existing books comics and video
games watch the snake of nerd culture
devour its own tail in a movie based on
a pre-existing book based on
pre-existing movies comics and video
games so this is how imagination dies
with thunderous applause ready player
one enter the oasis of virtual world and
let you be anything you want from a
novel you joined a boy band later the
love child of David Bowie and Admiral
Ackbar you can see hear and feel
everything that happens pause but since
you can pause we actually don't know
that those characters aren't already in
the Oasis unoriginal well the thing is
they're there like 20 or 30 years of pop
culture between today and the era that
this movie takes place in so sure they
could be the participle might be a
cereal mascot yeah that's something
really interesting they could have done
was like you could almost commentate
Jesus I'm still so tired from San Diego
comic-con
you could almost comment on our pop
culture obsessions today by just
inventing yeah future to like a like it
was a Jaws 3-d or something like that
like where the but I thought that was
part of the message in the movie was the
fact that there was no new pop culture
and that's what the what part of the
problem we'll probably brought me
showing its completely ceased to advance
they were only caught in things from the
past and there was no innovation no one
was paying attention to the world in
front of him so is a stagnant culture I
mean it was yet to me it was but then
that was also sort of undercut and maybe
we'll get into it later because it was
like that was by mandate of the
reclusive 80's geek who was like you
need to know everything I'm into which
is the 80s and 90s to have
chance at being a king or whatever so me
he kind of froze it in place by being
like you need to look at everything I
used to look at and honor everything I
think is valuable is that exactly what
every studio executive is doing right
now look at the box office charts what
yeah literally it's not like because Bob
Iger you know loves I don't know Disney
I think he's just bending over backwards
to give the people what they want
weather but isn't interesting to look at
it though because he's you know I mean
he is like very honored and everyone's
really obsessed with him and I may be
the movie doesn't hit it hard enough but
I do Dan like the idea that like they're
stuck in this because this guy was stuck
in his own Arrested Development and that
wasn't good for him and therefore like
not good for his creation right and I
think in the in the book like it
Gunter's good thirst
Gunter's are I just think of other
penguin from adventure time gun - the
it's kind of a dwindling group of people
as time goes on and no one's making any
progress like it's only a dedicated few
people who still you know know every
word to you know mannose hands a fader
eyes keep going and feel everything that
happens but since you can throw it by
running on a treadmill that's nobody
bodies ooh and the whole experience
probably smells like ass really air at
that van I mean crack a window or
something clan up with five Easter egg
hunters who lack the self-awareness to
not call themselves Gunter's hunters
hunters and content Gunter's as in egg
hunters
there's parsable at artemis star-crossed
lovers hiding a tragic secret that
underneath their hot online avatars
they're both hot offline real people but
she's god of birthmark mmm
a faint discoloration on her face and
you can barely see it in most lighting
no humanity I will I will I got I saw
the Citiz
lucky to see this at a critics screening
that's too rough Cornett there's a part
he says something like you know like you
know of course I like you and she just
looks at me she just goes yeah she's
beautiful just like the idea of and I
remember before this movie came out I
was just like I know what they're gonna
do they're gonna cast the Hollywood
people into these role and that is they
didn't do it quite as bad as I thought
they might but cuz he's a little you
know they make him up to be a little you
know I don't know if it's padding or if
he actually gained a little weight but
he's not like super lean and he looks
looks like a breeze but in the bin the
the book he's got the acne and he gains
a lot of weight over the course of it
and you know everybody's sort of much
more average and they very they really
sanded the edges of that offer this
movie but yeah that for this one was
just like it's like it's a it's a nice
message but at the same time like you
could tell they're like but we have to
we can't
it can't be can't be too too much but
some another poster well I think I would
have admired if they could really no I
don't think that this movie would have
been any worse for it no I don't think
it would have been and I think it might
have served even more positive to some
people instead of this which is like it
felt like lip service if I'm being
honest to the book and you know again in
most shots it's not even they keep her
hair over it or it's not that noticeable
and I and I do she has a sweet tat yeah
right it looks like she did that herself
to like look you know like Kano from
Mortal Kombat yeah yeah I don't know I
felt like they could have they had the
license to do it maybe a little more
realistically but that's just me yeah
it's not a perfect film now you can't
can't you have a floor of attractiveness
you have to be above to be in a movie
I guess I remember someone who had read
the book before casting had come out
said they were hoping that the girl that
played Bev and stranger things okay I
was gonna play her yeah yeah
justice justice from it would have been
interesting it would have been better
yeah yeah well the fact that she's
girl by talking while you insist I toe
the Japanese martial artist who in
reality is a Japanese martial artist and
show the gamer no one can believe is an
eleven-year-old boy even though everyone
who's ever beat you and halo ends up
being a year old boy sound all the way
you can be anything you want and they
all went with slight exaggerations of
themselves come on
you ten foot tall bag of Funyuns a
talking Raptor Allen a cloud made of
microscopic Steve Buscemi's do something
creative yeah that's kind of a cell
phone because all those things we listed
are already existing eyepiece yes true
but they're slight twists on their just
let more obscure references so we're
really no better than anyone else no
although I would have liked if H was at
all a ten-foot tall people I really
wanted a 500 foot tall oprah from
wrinkle in time charging in the battle
leaked monster reese witherspoon
yes flying in behind her that's what the
oasis would really be like his wrinkle
in time right no it'd be just dicks yeah
flying dildo yes Dixon jizz yeah just a
barracks of Dixon Jim V for Vendetta
masters yeah anyway do something
creative watch out for the evil CEO
Nolan Sorento who's got an evil plan to
use the Oasis to make money pause real
quick I forgot a vest chair how does it
how does it work how does the game work
how does he run how does it run because
some people have a whole treadmill at
the end he's in the van like with
Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon wirework
attached to him yeah
some people like there's different an
input it's like a like a PC like you can
play the gamepad keyboard and mouse VR
trooper headset or whatever yeah I feel
like it's just debts of peripherals it's
a fair enough explanation that's the
executive sharper image Brookstone
deluxe massage gosh tickling chair okay
okay that's fair yeah I'd have that one
that one looks comfy it's really to make
money as opposed to the current CEO who
uses the Oasis to make money I bought
all these power-ups for this challenge
and I've lost it all
now these Gunter's must find three keys
to win control the Oasis hidden by an
awkward Willy Wonka
using their videogame skills pop culture
knowledge it's based on the best-selling
book by Stephen King who hated the movie
and what they probably could have
guessed just by looking at him his
biggest fear was kissing a crawl because
in this world the best people to run a
trillion-dollar company are the biggest
snobs at a Comic Con a fanboy knows that
play welcome mom I'm not waiting my life
if you go to night school that was the
point is they are now they have no
business acumen and they are now they're
real gamers they're real fans is the
ultimate they know I hate her
yeah is the ultimate fanservice movie
just general fanservice because this
tells you that being a fan makes you
better than everybody else
yeah not just being a fan know knowing
things I'm just saying it would be so
easy to embezzle money from that company
now but yeah nobody is keeping the books
at gregarious games yet sitting there
you know overlooking the mergers with
whatever I don't want to know the
complicated mergers have had to go to
license the IP so that any single one of
them of all time could be used as an
avatar oh they're definitely like some
like crooked CFO is gonna come up to
them and like do the right fortnight
dance like know all the words to like
one week yeah that's cool yeah yeah I
mean cuz you know Simon Pegg is looking
after but he's not gonna be there
forever
older man by the way him with an
American accent that didn't even notice
it was him until you pointed I was like
was like the American voice really
you became face blind to Simon Pegg yes
completely really completely I didn't
just yeah I just got uncanny valley yeah
I was like I there's something I know
this person but well whatever I guess
it's just some character actor
and then you said Simon Pegg and it all
the coffee cup but I mean it's not like
he was in prosthetics the whole movie
he's like no it was just it was just the
voice yeah it was so weird he might as
well have been giving a child a bell on
the Polar Express like he was so weird
to be with that voice just bizarre to me
it's like cuz if Tom Hanks walked up to
me and was like and I grabbed now okay
like who are you with my whole like
British British actor theory thing like
they can all do American and Texas as
hell most of them can and but we can't
none of us can like it doesn't work the
other way around it's like the closest
we've gotten is like Renee Zellweger so
it doesn't work for Tony Junior has a
really good one so wait so like what
Renee Zellweger was in Bridget Jones's
Diary did you watch that and go like who
is that it doesn't work the other way
but like Simon no I do solid American
French people get off the hook for this
a lot actors and it's like well actually
no that guy's Australian nevermind
Charlie Hunnam did you watch Doctor
Strange and be like who is this guy Wow
I'm never small like small exception I
don't know it's just so weird to me that
you would like he sounded American he
just sounded like that Will Ferrell's
character that can't control the sound
of his voice small exception smart gun
by a British robot does ooh yep I'm
sorry it's just
ii-i'll move on it just baffles me that
that the voice was that different that
you couldn't recognise got old hey cor
he's wearing a sweater but he just
didn't look Simon peckish to me there's
something right well we'll see you shot
him later right well he's in the old age
of a car that yes yeah what
you make no sense JT now play the
trailer do you like references oh yeah
because this movies got more references
than a Big Bang Theory episode about the
Justice League challenges mr. Anatomy
edition of Trivial Pursuit of ominous
nerve touchdowns
Batman Holy Hand Grenade what
oddly specific late 90s stuff okay Oh am
I being Punk'd to pay for that Something
About Mary hairdo Goldeneye playing is
our job and an extended seat I mean the
past just for just to like put this in
context this is all 80s and 90s stuff
then there into the year is 2040
subtract 50 60 years from 2040 to get to
phase emma is my math right ish so 50 or
60 years ago holiday was growing up in
the eighties right but I'm just saying
for us it would be like if we were huge
nerds of what the sixties right like if
we just help each movies yeah we just
loved is it seven okay here it's us it
would basically be like if we invented
the Oasis mm-hmm and stocked them with
our favorite things what would it be
which would be like Elvis and Beach Boys
well no I'm just doing the time gap and
just saying it didn't happen today if it
happened today these people in the in
the future are so nostalgic for
something 50 60 years ago if we were to
static for 50 60 years ago we'd be like
swingers swing dancing all this way to a
limit of the 1990 Spencer it did we were
Squirrel Nut Zippers but I want to
pardon the f-word I apologize since yeah
I wanted to go to that Oasis where it's
all swingers and and like bowling stop
come bowling shirts like Tiki culture
that's my Owens anyways he's done a job
and an extended sequence that asks what
if Kubrick was so harder for cash that
he sold the shining to Universal Studios
Florida I'm sorry I hated this baby
there was a so was a shining maze at
Halloween Horror Nights yeah cool and a
way that did come sure
actually happened if they do the blood
thing no that would require a lot of
cleanup and a lot of angry people yeah
yeah they do eyes wide shut orgy room
nope just to that just uh just shining
if there was a Cooper clan like what
else is that because I feel like then
the shining blood is like a lazy river
yeah that just goes around the whole
park ride the space baby yeah well I was
gonna say there's like a monolith
death-drop it's just they built a giant
monolith in the center of it that you
drop down mm-hmm the the like show for
kids is just the dual from Barry Lyndon
where he Sun shoots him yeah you do a
version of the the cars right at Disney
with the big wheel through the Overlook
Hotel and of the shining right yeah it'd
be good what do you do for Clockwork
Orange
I guess that's just like security or you
just have roving gangs milk bar parks of
glory yeah it's a good park oh yeah
sounds AI count
sure yeah hey all right all right keep
going there was a b-minus on that bit
from us ride-along Neri director Cameron
Neil burger as he brings his trademark
wonder to a tale of an America and chaos
where we ignore our problems by using
recycle pop cultures and escape and only
take action when our corporate overlords
threatened to put more ads in our
pay2win video games while the offline
world continues to slide into extreme
poverty and environmental collapse who
doesn't love a good fantasy am i right
good one Steve
starring miles Taylor
I mean Ansel L know I mean all didn't
Ellen right I mean no Tyler fairness we
have no Tyler shared sweet then
meddlesome H to the is org how cool TG
Miller's in this sit absolutely no word
or a [ __ ] word all right come on that's
not immediately reading assignment babe
yes it is that literally simon Pegg's
face with like two wrinkles added to it
like that is you're a huge Pegman that i
am a penguin yes that's true that guy
could totally be a Downton Abbey
troublemaker you know like a Lord
Grantham's because Hugh Bonneville ex
footman who's no he's got a chamber full
of secrets I'll grant you okay the old
age makeup but like he literally is in
the movie as himself currently yeah fair
enough that that's also obviously son
he's not dressed house now for me he's
not know how Simon Pegg usually dresses
just based on I'm only going out for
Shawna did you think he always wears a
white dress shirt with a red tie yeah
that's I see that more than I see him
I've Simon Pegg face-blindness for me he
looks like Simon Pegg right now cuz he's
not speaking but if he was just talking
in his American accent oh as Simon Pegg
yeah luzhin well yeah I just lose him
what's worse with me and Jovi get good
noobs and this guy staring directly into
the camera while he strangles ty
Sheridan weird that's unsettling are the
are troopers
but it's a comic-con crowd picked that
one yeah Holy Hand Grenade this bother
me wait this movie is 90% references and
you didn't count 1 2 5 before using the
Holy Hand Grenade of Antioch a fanboy
knows a hater this is a this is a versus
a bone that I have to pick what the
movie was that the whole movie is about
how you know everything that you use is
based on your extensive knowledge of it
and there's no way in the world of ready
player one that you could ever use the
Holy Hand Grenade of Antioch without
counting one two five these are a
hundred percent I've had to do the the
what was the invocation from was it like
from Excalibur or something like like
that magic spell that TJ Miller had to
or remove that thing like it was from
crawl or some [ __ ] yeah like there's
no way that you wouldn't have to do one
to five there's no way that that would
work without having to count to one two
I was watching that I was like alright
God too far nope why else with the Holy
Hand Grenade of Antioch be in the movie
right have to do the one two five
because then they throw it and then I'm
like okay well they didn't count one two
five so I better just explodes into a
bunch of man-eating rabbits and the
rabbits up no and great it's like you
know it's if you go all the way if
you're gonna do it do the damn thing yep
so you're looking for some nerd
consultants for ready player to look at
we're here yeah help
let's see what was not funny enough to
go in yay and show the gamer no one can
believe is an 11 year old boy even
though everyone who's ever be 2 and halo
ends up being an 11 year old boy nice
cuz I wasn't caring to him work sucks 69
and I will kill you
starring party McGee Forrest gunned
except Artemus Cowell not one of those
fake gamer girls dr. Dre presents the
critic Paul H Helen Hunt's college and
Steve Brule fifth member player one
actions about ethics in video game
economics Oh
Goldeneye playing is a job I use odd
jobs so don't wonder the guy had no
friends no bastard
no Goldeneye League with their son moms
job role that's called your and that's a
good show such a weird thing to say in
the future the word man strange
maybe cheapo bastard is one of my
all-time favorite epic voice guy reads
cheapo blaster people bastard yes that
one got me yeah yeah this was a fun one
to watch with the live crowd I'd never
in my wildest dreams would I have
thought a c-level Saban property
reference would get the title know your
audience come on your references are
what we traffic in oh yeah yeah also
with this movie traffic said yes exactly
oh really like how could we sit here and
criticize us how could we sit here and
criticize this movie because I know what
area traffic there I know and they're
like we know you nerds you're gonna eat
this up and I'm like I am but I'm not
happy about it it's too obvious make it
more subtle sneak it into me
praising anyways guys let's just talk
about our favorite rush song and then
we'll be back next week Joe what do you
get mmm no that's a yes song I
immediately was a Tom Sawyer and was
like that's yes yeah yeah wait lame
answer but Tom Sawyer electron Giotto
Dan what is yours I'll also go Tom
Sawyer okay this is I can't think of any
I love rush but I can't think of
anything I was on a death train
yesterday my brains gone Tom Sawyer yeah
hear more about the death train on next
week's we'll be exploiting your
nostalgia for 1990s film that only weird
so we're gonna read it Bert we're doing
ready player one again yes we're doing
it again ready for once we come back
next week to see how true that statement
really is
today's episode was brought to you by
the US Army find out more by clicking
the link below
you